Now, it seemed that this condition can only hold when c was in double quote.
So first c was in double quote and then c was in less than sign.
>From all of this information, we can reconstruct the input
that was passed over to remove HTML markup.
It must have been something along the lines of first a double quote and then an opening tag.
Between these two events, c being a double quote and c being an opening tag,
there could also have been other characters before.
But in our deduction, none of these matter.
For us, it is sufficient to know that indeed there is an input,
which can cause this assertion to fail.
And second, while we are doing the reasoning, we actually also stumbled
across the condition that was wrong here.
>From the line of our reasoning, we can now deduce that
if this condition had not been true, then for this input the assertion would not have failed.
By adding appropriate parenthesis here, we can make sure that this input will not cause
the assertion to fail and thereby through deduction we have found a fix
without executing the program even once.
And now for a really tough quiz in which you can show how good your deduction skills are.
If I have applied this fix with this parenthesis, can this assertion ever fail? If yes, provide an example.
If no, write down the individual steps of your deduction
and let's see whether this is elementary, my dear Watson.